In an electronic world where a few taps on a
device keyboard sends an invitation or
greeting card, it's not all that common
anymore to receive something printed the old
fashioned way.
Yet there's nothing quite as elegant as the
crisp recessed print that traditional
letterpress printing produces.
Letter press printing is a centuries old
method that's making a comeback.
The printing press makes an impression in
the paper with raised type as it applies the
ink. The printer first sketches out some
design ideas.
Then he detours into digital technology,
finalizing the colors and composition and
choosing the font in traditional metal type.
He cuts paper to the size of the greeting
card he's making.
The paper is 100% cotton, which is more
pliable than standard wood fiber paper, thus
enabling a deeper impression.
Cotton paper is more delicate, so he has to
cushion it while cutting.
Otherwise the clamp holding the stack would
dent the paper.
Now it's time to set up.
He locates the selected font in the type
cabinet.
Each individual character, called a sort, is
backwards because backwards type prints
forwards. He finds the swords for the first
line of text and lines them up left to right
and upside down in what's called a composing
stick.
Once he completes the type of the line
called a form, he clamps it in position.
Then he takes a metal frame called a chase
and mounts the form at a specific position
inside the frame, filling the excess space
with blocks of wood called furniture.
Just below the piece of furniture that's
underneath the form.
He places a compression device called a coin
and expands it with a key.
This locks the form in position.
He chooses each ink color from a fan deck,
then follows the recipe to mix it.
This is color extender, which works like
paint thinner, diluting a dark color to a
lighter shade.
He mixes the color extender into the ink,
blending the two ingredients thoroughly.
When the color matches the fan deck sample,
he places a glob on a piece of cardboard and
takes the mixture over to the printing
press.
He applies it in dots all over the ink disk.
Then he pumps on the treadle to run the
rollers back and forth across the disc.
This spreads the ink over the disc and onto
the rollers.
He inserts the chase containing the form
into what's called the bed of the press.
Now for the test run.
The printer pulls the lever to bring the bed
and platen together, so that the form inked
by the rollers creates an ink filled
impression in the paper.
If the print is off a bit, he marks the
correct position by pencil and installs gauge
pins which will hold the paper there.
Now he's ready to start printing.
There's no automation here.
He manually places one sheet at a time in
the gauge pens.
The ink dries quickly because it's rubber
based and because cotton paper absorbs well.
This printers technique is a hybrid of
traditional and modern approaches, as he uses
computer generated graphics.
He sends the digital file to a company that
makes a polymer printing plate, which he
mounts on an aluminum base that fits in the
chase of the press.
He switches plates to do the next graphic in
a different color layered over the first.
The polymer plates marry the old and new
technology by making it possible to print
computer generated graphics by traditional
letter press.
After printing the inside of this greeting
card as well, he uses a scoring rule mounted
in another press to make a perfectly
straight fold line down the middle of the
paper. The result is beautiful textured
print
on elegant cotton paper, just like the good
old days before.
Inkjets e-cards and Evites.
Bamboo ceramic lights add a touch of Zen to
any space made of ceramic and inspired by
bamboo. They resemble bundles of tropical
grasses, but they're not exact replications.
These light fixtures offer an artistic
interpretation of an exotic element from the
natural world.
Trying to create a tropical ambience.
It's all in the lighting.
These ceramic lights celebrate the natural
beauty of bamboo and set the mood.
Making the ceramic casing starts with a
slurry of clay and water known as slip.
A propeller mixer evenly distributes the
particles.
The slip flows through a hose and into
plaster molds.
The artisan controls the amount going in,
ensuring that each one is filled just below
the brim. Over three hours, the clay
thickens and congeals along the edges.
After pouring out the remaining slip, he
trims the clay casting, which has a putty
like consistency.
After leaving it to solidify a bit more, he
carefully disassembles the mold, revealing
the clay casting with a bamboo like detail.
After curing overnight, the casting further
solidifies and the color lightens using a
knife. He adds more definition to some of
the detail and cleans up the rough edges.
He also shaves off protrusions formed where
the mold parts came together.
He lightly sands the entire bamboo ceramic
casting to smooth over any remaining
imperfections. Using a wet sea sponge, he
washes the entire
casting. This softens the clay on the
surface and gets rid of any minute scratches
left by the sanding.
The artisan then cuts holes in the back of
the casting.
One is for installing the light socket, and
the other is to run wires to the electrical
junction box.
With the clay surface still moist, he carves
nodes or joints into the bamboo canes.
He also cuts wide vertical lines to create
the effect of cracks that occur in bamboo
naturally when they dry out.
After firing the clay casting in a kiln and
then cooling it overnight, the material has
become a strong, durable piece of ceramic.
This craftsperson examines it for
imperfections and then begins the painting
process. She sprays a very light yellow
paint onto the bamboo ceramic.
This gives the piece just a hint of color,
but it provides the desired undertone.
Next, she mixes a green oil paint with
thinner and then brushes the mix into the
grooves and notches.
This accentuates these areas.
She also brushes it onto the edges of the
bamboo ceramic lightbox to better define the
profile. Using a soft cotton cloth.
She blots up some paint from the palette and
wipes it on the ceramic.
This softens the brushstrokes and gives the
ceramic cane structure a hint of green.
She sets the light casing on a revolving
stand and inspects the coverage.
She then applies a liberal amount of brown
paint to the entire piece, and the brown
color completely overpowers the green and
yellow paints.
She rubs off a lot of the brown paint.
This tones it down and subtly brings out the
other colors.
This produces color variations that evoke
the different tones of dried bamboo.
The paint transforms the piece.
A technician inserts the socket and pulls
the wires through one of the holes and out
the back. He secures the socket in the light
box from the back with a washer and nut, and
that completes this bamboo ceramic light
fixture.
Making. It takes roughly one week, but the
final result is very unique.
While providing illumination.
It may also be an object of conversation.